en 1985 orphée est devenue une pop star
eurydice et japonaises le film s'appelle
parking il est signé jacques demy clin
d'oeil jean marais leur fait de jean
cocteau est aussi dans ce film cette
fois dans le rôle d'un dess leur fait de
jacques demy c'est francis huster avant
d'en parler avec lui quelques images du
film la scène du tribunal monsieur
chanteurs populaires de grand talent
mari pendant vingt ans la rumeur
publique
il cause est connue et mais je crois
mais est-ce que cela vous rend heureux
j'aime chanter chanter c'est donner du
bonheur et public meuros moenner à ce
compte par exemple j'aime pas les
chansons que je répète elle me résiste
voyez ce que je veux dire il se pose ici
pour parler de vos chansons et des
voleurs 1 pourquoi suis-je issue juste
si vraiment il ne sait rien ne vous a
pas prévenu prévenu
vous ne lui avais rien n'est pas de ma
compétence bien
il s'agit d'une erreur une erreur
regrettable
comme toutes les serrures nous avons
autre date de sortie mais votre entrée
est pas encore prévu hier les chiffres
correspond carrière j'ai toujours été
brouillé avec les chiefs hamilton
en d'autres termes d'après notre fichier
vous étonner mais vraiment on n'est pas
encore programmée non reconnu aussi il
m'arrive france pisier flags habibou
reçoivent ou d'ici toute à l'heure où
débute ce jour n'en voyais à l'actualité
très sombre c'est vrai qu'il fallait au
moins une bonne nouvelle par jour et
dont on peut penser en général que la
sortie de vos films est plutôt considéré
comme une bonne nouvelle
alors c'est pas sauvés mercredi prochain
le film sort mercredi
alors ces parkings coproduit par fr3 a
raté le festival de cannes pour la bonne
raison que vous l'avez terminée il ya
trois jours
parfois je me dis qu'est qu'on a dit il
a été écarté là de la compétition alors
qu'en fait c'est à dire que c'est
toujours c'est toujours compliqué j'ai
un jeune producteur formidable qui lui
voulait à cannes moi je ne voulais pas
je ne voulais pas parce que j'étais à
cannes j'ai tout raflé je l'appelle d'or
tout ce qu'il fallait j'étais un homme
comblé
ravi joyeux veillée des zones ng10 mis
en place aux jeunes effectivement assez
chiche avoir les gones ces candidats
puisque c'est très bien oui mais les
bêtes après deux films n'étaient pas
prêts que j'aidais mon producteur mais
dépressionnaire tu me diras quinze jours
dans situe pas mais ils essaient suis
désolé mon papa la cannelle qui meurent
près j'ai terminé vendredi dernier
voilà toute l'histoire du cam qui est un
peu ridicule alors la première surprise
évidemment qu'on va avoir
c'est francis huster d'abord pourquoi ce
choix et comment se fait-il brusquement
qu'il chante parce que dans les dix
premières minutes ils chantent et c'est
là tout de même qui aura chocques
probablement chez les gens parce que
c'est pas une pop star
pourquoi l'avoir choisi de lui et bien
parce que j'avais il y avait deux façons
de faire le film prendre un chanteur qui
savent jouer ou bien un acteur qui
chassent santé or la partie action était
très importante la partie jeu et dans le
film trop importante parce que ces pages
musicales
c'est l'histoire monde a chanté un
chanteur pop effectivement mais c'est
pas n'importe quel chanteur ce chanteur
devant un certain charme doigts
je vais être très dangereux altérant
parce que c'était une question
faussement malveillantes
en réalité avant de voir et les simples
mais minutes j'étais dégoûté et puis
après je fais complètement captivés par
son jeu et par votre film parce que
finalement votre sujet bon on fait bien
sûr à l'école et plus tard certains
d'entre nous s'en souviennent et
finalement n'en a pas besoin
c'est un film un peu sur la solitude des
stars et c'est un de vos thèmes depuis
longtemps vous l'avez déjà esquissé oui
on fire beaucoup de choses ça tu aimes
ça s'est vu sur la création ça thèmes
aussi sûr c'est une histoire d'amour
formidable et puis quelque chose qui est
intéressant aussi c'était cette espèce
de permanence dans les thèmes c'est à
dire qu'on parle d'eux comme ça de la
grèce antique jusqu'à nos jours et on a
finalement toujours les mêmes besoins
je sais une permanence qui je crois
rassure complètement ça rassure les
hommes dans leur coeur
il y aussi le rêve et il ya aussi une
apparition extraordinaire c'est votre
afrique japonaise
oui alors expliquer ce choix également
parce que tout est d autant tout est
ambigu et tout est finalement je te fait
rêver c'est comme la vie aussi c'est à
dire jouer une histoire d'amour
romantique formidable ont acquis besoin
d'aimer quand même bon dans 85 c'est pas
évident donc il fallait une pour
eurydice puisque orphée et eurydice et
un amour comme sa considérable
un bourg qu'on comprend pas vraiment il
fallait quelqu'un d'unique suzanne fabre
élu d'ailleurs venus d'ailleurs et un
peu étranger
lui aussi et ça c'est très important un
film est créatrice puisqu'elle est
sculpteur ça me paraissait important
d'avoir quelqu'un d'autre quelqu'un de
rare on a vu jean marc ela qui avait
sonné l'autre l'autre grand d'autres
régions cocteau comment il s'est senti
dans votre film vous en a parlé
bien sûr on a parlé beaucoup et moi
j'aime beaucoup jean parce que quand
j'étais quand j'étais adolescent que
j'ai aussi aimable c'était une idole
comme ça et puis j'avais tourné avec lui
peau d'âne et la première chose que jean
même ai dit c'est ça m'a fait vraiment
de la peine c'est que il n'a pas tourné
depuis peau d'un tiers depuis 15 ans les
hawks et un retour extraordinaire et
j'étais heureux de le dire mais voilà il
est là il est pareil et les formidables
et un orri faut ajouter aussi pour ceux
qui l'ignorent que c'est peut-être le
premier film qui n'est pas entièrement
chanté et lalancette environ à une
volonté de votre part
oui parce que
bon j'ai fait avec moi que je remarque
c'est une chambre en ville et il n'y a
pas marché parce que beaucoup je crois à
cause du choc comme ça est bon je me
suis musicale en france effectivement
être des problèmes et j'ai fait des
films pas chanter comme lola ou la
bêtise orge en face je fais autre chose
quoi et celui-ci bon a forcément une
merveilleuse musique de legrand c'est
michel qui a fait les chansons puisque
c'est l'histoire d'un chanteur mais on
parle il ya des drames five c'est un il
ya même eu un suspense une ville kadhafi
dit qu'il est poétique mais il exige
oui mais c'est à plus policier si par
moment cette recherche de nos dames sont
terminées henry chapier le fis n'est pas
allé à cannes parce que jacques demy
modeste mais janet n'est pas vous auriez
marqué pour vous
à oui j'aurais vaudrait bout parce que
tu voulais ça change totalement quand
même ça change un peu de ce qu'on voit
c'est courageux donc je vais y aller
mais ses jambes en ce moment je voulais
dire que kylie est acteur merveilleux
comme laurent malet ou si je ne parle
pas là et qui est magnifique et klein et
marie france pisier tout un tas demande